[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
[Music]
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
go for a walk
i have an owner and the superman let me
just iron that out
they should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who was he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i in destructive dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any super power
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
which is which is crazy i didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water fountain
out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine shield what is a k-9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
[Music]
anybody want to switch powers
you